[Musique]
chantal saint-aulaye bonjour bonjour
vous êtes candidate aux élections
législatives où vous présenter dans la
circonscription du nord sur la liste les
patriotes alors pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à ce scrutin oui bonjour
aux auditeurs de matinée que la première
alors tout d'abord je ne suis pas une
politicienne par contre je suis
quelqu'un qui a toujours été engagée
engagé parce que j'ai j'ai été déjà élu
sur la commune de schoelcher conseillère
municipale lors de la première mandature
de du maire actuel
engagé dans le monde associatif puisque
dans le monde du handicap
particulièrement puisque je suis en
fauteuil roulant depuis plus d'une
quarantaine d'années suite à un accident
de la route
engagé syndicalement puisque ce sont ces
masses et même mon combat 12,2 toujours
d'aujourd'hui encore donc et puis
pourquoi pourquoi me présenter en verre
fait les patriotes sont venus me
chercher et j'ai beaucoup réfléchi puis
finalement j'ai j'ai dit oui parce que
en fait florian philippot que je ne
connaissais pas jusqu'à il ya deux ans
encore est quelqu'un qui se bat depuis
plus de deux ans notamment pour qu'on
recouvre toutes nos libertés qui sont
étiolés au fur et à mesure depuis depuis
ces deux années donc moi fort de cette
crise en fait sanitaires j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi en fait je n'ai pas hésité une
seconde parce qu'effectivement je pense
que nos libertés sont chères liberté de
nos enfants de nos petits enfants parce
que je suis mère et grand mère alors
quels seront les deux ou trois projets
prioritaires pour l'ensemble de la
martinique que vous comptez défendre si
vous êtes élu à l'assemblée nationale
bon il ya beaucoup de choses mais
effectivement pour la martinique en tout
cas tout savoir d'abord que et enfin on
n'est pas sans savoir qu'une élection
nationale avant d'être une élection
locale donc
ce sont des projets avant tout nationaux
mais pour la martinique ya d'abord la
reconnaissance
effectivement qu'on veut nous faire
qu'on veut nous bafoué sur le
chlordécone parce que je trouve que
c'est quelque chose de petit monde des
normes il ya aussi
voir comment on peut aujourd'hui
avec ce qui nous arrive depuis quelques
années sur avec la halle les algues
laddh les sargasses donc il ya bien
plein de projets en ce moment lanvin qui
sont déjà en cours mais qu'il faut
promouvoir et défendre à l'école normale
notamment et puis et puis
médias tellement ya tellement de choses
qu'on pourrait faire notamment notamment
et prioritairement sur le nord et l'est
alors justement j'ai à lille venir le
nord concrètement ça serait quoi pour
vous les deux priorités ou trois maximum
pourquoi 2 pourquoi 3 enfin j'en sais
rien voir du foot en a besoin mais
effectivement le nord le nord en tout
cas et une eu un secteur un peu oublié à
chaque fois de de la martinique parce
qu'on privilégie notamment et pour
beaucoup de choses le centre le sud
parce qu'on pour les plages notamment
sow mais mais mais désenclaver un peu le
nord
a porté à apporter de la visibilité sur
tout ce qu'on peut faire sur sur
comment je peux dire ça le tout ce qui
est vert tous qu'écologique tout ce qui
est je ne veux pas rentrer dans ce dans
ce domaine là parce qu'on pourrait dire
que c'est un peu lobbyistes de dire ça à
mes hommes il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire sur le nord de la martinique
notamment pour le désenclavement du
désenclavement oui le du nord alors
qu'avez vous à dire à rajouter si vous
devez vous adresser aux électeurs
alors d'abord d'abord je veux leur dire
que effectivement on ne me connaît pas
comme quelqu'un de de politique mais je
suis quelqu'un de deux combative
[Musique]
la crise montre que aujourd'hui les
politiques
n'écoutent pas la population dans la
plupart des cas notamment sur tout ce
qui est obligation de la vaccination et
bien d'autres choses moi je dis
qu'aujourd'hui les politiques sont là
non pas pour faire ce qu'ils ont envie
de faire comme ils ont envie de faire
mais ce sont des élus qui doivent
d'abord s'occuper de ce que la
population dit et veut donc moi je serai
là pour faire valoir le droit de la
population et écouter ce que la
population veut en priorité donc en tout
cas m'engager c'est
être certaine d'écouté en priorité ce
que la population veut chantal
saint-aunès merci je vous remercie
[Musique]